wird ihnen präsentiert von der leyen für
alle wohl engert oder weniger lang weg
sind
[Musik]
michael kastner und mike wittner aus
thun suchen das einfache leben mit ihren
kindern wandern sie aus nach costa rica
beatrice und marcel buholzer aus dem
kanton solothurn wurde noch einmal
durchstarten auf kreta eröffnen sie eine
bar
von clarus nach australien familie
landolt möchte mit den ureinwohnern
zusammenarbeiten und betreibt ein ferien
resort in down under
[Musik]
auf kreta ist ein besonderer tag marcel
buchholz bekommt endlich den schlüssel
für die neue bar wenn alles klappt
doch vorher muss kaffeekasse verarztet
werden
tasche hat sich neben eingefangen
die salbe hat buchholz als ehemaliger
tierarzt in der schweiz empfohlen
[Gelächter]
tricks und marcel machen sich an euch
auf den weg zum anwalt für die
schlüsselübergabe beim letzten termin
ist die hausbesitzerin die den
kaufvertrag für die bar ebenfalls
unterschreiben muss nicht erschienen
in der letzten folge von auf und auf
wunsch wiegelte muscle buchholzer
bereits große pläne für seine war
marcel hinterlegte 40.000 euro ablöse
beim anwalt trickst und das alles zu
schnell check
in australien versuchte miriam landolt
das ferienressort zum laufen zu bringen
ehe man schön muster in der alten heimat
weiter geld verdienen
mike wittner und nicole gerstner sind
mit ihrem neuen eigenheim endlich
richtig in costa rica angekommen für
ihre kinder habe begann der kontron für
den ersten schultag
[Musik]
mit schweizerischer pünktlichkeit
erreichen marcel und tricks die kanzlei
des anwalts in sneek
auch die griechen sind alle rechtzeitig
hier sogar hausbesitzerin pop ist da der
vertragsunterzeichnung steht nichts mehr
im weg
mit der schlüsselübergabe ist marcel
endlich sein eigener chef
maklerin l hat die bar vermittelt und
wird in beiden weiter hilfreich zur
seite stehen
jetzt geht es los nun beginnt eine
großartige zeit
ich denke dass das schiff in das ist
eine gute idee
so schnell wollte tricks eigentlich
nicht chefin werden die ehemalige
schuhverkäuferin hat sich vorgenommen
ihr neues leben ruhiger anzugehen
muscle hingegen kann es kaum erwarten
loszulegen
mit dem mixer pürieren und lässt sich
das natürlich schon ganz besorgt also
das ist
ein aufbruch in eine selbständige aber
unsichere zukunft
[Musik]
darum andere ist der sommer eingezogen
hochsaison im freien krieg resort
[Musik]
die familie landolt beginnt den tag
endlich ist vater schön wieder zu besuch
nach drei langen monaten in der schweiz
[Musik]
merian bereitet einen frühstückskorb für
gäste vor
das resort ist so gefragt wie nie
während der australischen sommerferien
sind alle neuen ferienhäuser ausgebucht
auf sie abgesehen nehmen landes jedoch
noch nicht genug
und man danke dass das noch markt ist
vor allem für die zwei noch deutlich
länger ständig gepusht
solange nicht genug geld reinkommt
behält vater für seinen job als
finanzchef in der schweiz
seine kinder sieht er so nur noch wenige
wochen im jahr das belastet die familie
zum
komponieren
[Musik]
für das ferienressort weitgehend allein
hilfe hat sie von einer putzfrau einem
gärtner und hausmeister und von mirja
der ältesten tochter
[Musik]
mit dem auto geht's rüber zu den gästen
in den ferienhäusern die wege sind weit
auf den 40 hektar großen gelände
haben sie gut geschlafen ja wunderbar
vielen dank mavenir verwöhnt uns sehr
über stehst du den korb mit harriet
hineintragen das geschäft läuft immer
besser aber noch besitzen die landolt
das ferienressort nicht sie müssen noch
2,4 millionen franken auftreiben
[Musik]
an der hertie school beginnt das neue
schuljahr
für turnschuhe und schussel ihn ist es
der erste schultag in der neuen heimat
die neuen mitschüler der kinder kommen
aus der ganzen welt und die lehre
sprechen nur spanisch oder englisch
[Musik]
tochter jaz elle 7 gegen ihn tun noch in
den kindergarten dort war sie bestens
integriert und hatte jede menge freunde
red
ja
in costa rica wird show soliden
eingeschult sie kennen jemanden und
versteht kaum ein wort
nicole sorgt sich vor allem um ihre
beiden kleineren kinder
sie hofft dass sie den tag gut
überstehen
der erste schultag für mike und nicole
fast so aufregend wie für ihre kinder ob
alles gut gehen wird
[Musik]
premiere in griechenland maßen und
tricks betreten als chefs die eigene
budget aus was den minister
durch die sparte schrott
das ganze für bands und ausarbeitung
poste und süßes und aus aber
das oasis und aus aber
weiter früchte kuriert seine kunst gar
nicht vorstellen wer
hat noch nicht beschrieben unter sich
nichts
weber hatte er noch die hoffnung dass
[Musik]
marcel weiß genau was er will ob die
touristen sich für seine ideen
begeistern das ist die große unbekannte
[Musik]
familie landolt hat nicht nur neue
ferienhäuser übernommen sondern auch
jede menge umschwung und der will
gepflegt werden
gärtner mit zeigt miriam wie man den
fahrbaren rasenmäher bedient
[Musik]
ehemann seal hat sich in sein
arbeitszimmer verkrochen die
finanzierung des ferienresorts lässt ihm
keine ruhe
ihr ursprünglicher plan investoren in
der schweiz zu finden ist gescheitert
nun hat schüler ein angebot einer
australischen bank die sache hat jedoch
einen haken
ja
bedeutet natürlich dass
das was sie kann man also
das ist eins
obendrauf möglich das verteilte
karstadt promoten hans nicht und das
ist nicht
[Musik]
hallo habt ihr mein mann gesehen
miriam begrüßt ihre australischen
freunde mit den aborigines vom stamm der
gumberger ist miriam schon seit über 20
jahren eng verbunden
eine einflussreiche stammesälteste lane
broker hat ihnen friday krieg als neue
heimat nahe gelegt für die aborigines
ist ist ein magischer ort und für elaine
stimmen die energien
heute morgen habe ich den linien noch
einmal nachgespürt und es ist nichts
gebrochen sie erscheinen mir sehr stark
wenn die linien offen sind droht
ungemach
sie sind aber fest geschlossen
nichts kann von außen einbringen das ist
ein gutes zeichen
gut gut zuhören
um die finanzierung zu regeln könnte
schon etwas magie gut gebrauchen
[Musik]
in santa teresa ist der erste schultag
bald überstanden micron nicole holen die
kinder ab
für sieben lange stunden musste nicole
ihrer drei kinder loslassen in einer für
sie unbekannten umgebung mit fremden
menschen
[Musik]
von menschen zu
tränen
die kleinen sind noch bei der kontrolle
der schultaschen
[Musik]
wie kommen morgen wieder das ist ein
gutes zeichen
wie gut für kassel ii das ist den großen
bruder joshua und wunder gibt
auf kreta neigt sich der tag dem ende
entgegen marcel und tricks können sich
in einem hafen restaurant einen prosecco
ich habe gerne
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen beginnt für marcel
das leben als betreiber einer bar
der blues
[Musik]
[Applaus]
rock und blues ist marcels leidenschaft
als junger mann ging er nach england und
hat dort für rockbands als roddick
erarbeitet später stand er am mischpult
bereits damals druck masse die idee
einer eigenen bar mit sich herum
jetzt mit 57 geht er seinen traum
endlich an
in sechs wochen möchte marcel erste
gäste bewirten bis dahin haben er und
ehefrau tricks die aufgaben klar
verteilt
[Musik]
ganz allein schafft marcel den umbau
aber doch nicht er hat bei nico
eingestellt
der grieche hat früher hier hinter dem
tresen gearbeitet
eine eigene rock und blues bar marcel
hat zur liebe seiner jugend tage
gefunden
der 21 jährige war
alles okay
das letzte bier wurde in diesem lokal
vor eineinhalb jahren gezapft seitdem
hat sich manch unliebsame bewohner
eingenistet
[Musik]
bis zur eröffnung gibt es für marcell
noch jede menge zu tun
[Musik]
auch in costa rica strotzt ein
auswanderer vor tatendrang marc widmann
möchte auf seinem neuen grundstück
ferienhäuser bauen
zusätzlich zu ihrer villa haben die
beiden noch 5000 quadratmeter land
gekauft darauf steht versteckt unter
palmen ein zweites kleines haus
auf diesem terrain hätten locker zwei
bungalows platz
was mit dem alten schuppen anstellen
maike und nicole sind sich darüber noch
nicht einig klar ist aber womit sie ihr
projekt beginnen wollen mit dem kleinen
haus das versteckt unter palmen auf
ihrem grundstück liegt direkt unterhalb
der villa ist dazu kann
ihr problem das haus ist noch bewohnt
[Musik]
ich schaue mich mal ein wenig um ok
danke schön
hier lebt eine familie aus nicaragua
carla mit zwei kindern und ihrem mann
carmelo er war beim vorbesitzer
hausmeister
[Musik]
dürfen wir reinkommen danke
die hausmeister familie hat kein festes
einkommen mehr jetzt wo nicole und mike
die wieder gekauft haben
und
sich selbst augenzwinkernd
eine quasi mit anderen oder nicht machen
und die zeit ist jetzt
aber
das ist ja ich wohne bisher
ist
schlecht
und das ist es kalt und projekte zum
konzept bonitätsnote zu
machen
[Musik]
eine zeit die sie benötigen und
verbuchen konnte und gäste
nach hause
angesichts der jungen familie schleichen
sich in das gewissen von maike und
nicole leise zweifel
vor ein paar minuten war der tatendrang
der beiden noch ungetrübt
[Musik]
miriam an schüler haben sich
durchgerungen das angebot der
australischen bank anzunehmen auch wenn
sie dafür weiterhin in der schweiz
arbeiten muss aber der kredit soll so
tief wie möglich sein sie wollen noch
einmal mit dem verkäufer des
ferienresorts verhandeln
[Musik]
dass es kauft
der führer ist das der punkt nur der
vertrag mit dem verkäufer ist schon
lange unterzeichnet nun wollen sie in
ändern
fehlerlose
besteht doch auch mio
[Musik]
oder sie muss glatt
privatbild ich raus bist
damals ohne
österreich das
lokal
für miriam und schütze jeder franken die
australische bank will für ihren kredit
happiger 8 prozent zinsen
das treffen findet in einem luxushotel
stand
[Musik]
verkäufer bild erwartet sie bereits
entschuldigung wir haben uns ein wenig
verfahren
wenn will mit dem preis nicht runter
geht müssten sie schlimmstenfalls
aufgeben
auf kreta ist marcel bereits wieder in
der bar große teile der einrichtung
müssen erneuert werden
marin l hat handwerker aus dem ort
mitgebracht zeigt ihm die toiletten ist
der installateur ich habe etwas
schreiben muss eine neue kostet
ungefähr
etwa 120 euro
also eine
das kann man nicht mehr
marcel es die schüsseln austauschen
sauberkeit gehört für ihn zum
geschäftsmodell
währenddessen beginnt ehefrau tricks zu
hause in länder den tag alleine
juni in oranges auf dem gehweg ordnet
die marke keine große sache
ganz machen sie aber
normal
ginge es nach tricks sollte masse in
einen gang zurückschalten
heute gut
aber
das würde total überrascht eigentlich
sollte unbedingt
aufrecht und machte
[Musik]
der 57-jährige massen hätte bereits zum
nächsten termin er muss zum
getränkelieferanten
sein angestellter barmen nico muss mit
ich komme morgen zu ihnen
momentan habe ich keine zeit ok ich
komme morgen früh
marcel ordert die grundausstattung für
seine bar alkohol für umgerechnet 6000
franken
brauchen wir alles sie würden viel
schreiben müssen
frau verstarb ist gut
400 euro der manager der am
[Musik]
anderen ende der welt in australien ist
die preisverhandlung mit verkäufer bis
zu ende
eine stunde lang haben schüler und
miriam gekämpft
500.000 weniger
sie sind sehr gut sind aber es sind
besonders leicht doch besteht darauf
dass er sein geld in einem monat bekannt
das heißt also man das letzte mal wenn
ich gas gebe heißt es
dass man jetzt noch nicht
sie mit -
das bedeutet auf als auch verkäufer zu
ziehen
ist nicht leicht
und
jetzt müssen nur noch die banken ziehen
[Musik]
mike und nicole haben einen termin mit
architekt gar die er hat den beiden ihr
neues haus vermittelt gar die israeli
und lebt schon seit vielen jahren in
costa rica
ich habe eine liste mit allen fragen wir
sind noch weit rückschlüssen maike und
nicole haben eine reihe von
kleinigkeiten aber ein punkt plagt sie
besonders wie sollen sie mit der
hausmeister familie umgehen
der nächste punkt auf meiner liste über
den wir reden müssen ich möchte gerne
die beiden bungalows bauen deshalb muss
der hausmeister auch ausziehen
wenn leute aus der schweiz zum helfen
kommen brauche ich für sie das haus zum
wohnen
ich habe es hausmeister carmela schon
vor einem monat gesagt dass er gehen
muss er sucht bereits nach einer neuen
bleibe
es ist nicht so dass sie ihn rauswerfen
für ihn ist es kein problem ihr braucht
also kein schlechtes gewissen zu haben
klar sie haben ein baby aber er weiß es
schon länger als einen monat aber
vielleicht kann der fans arbeiten zum
beispiel im garten wo er mike helfen
kann
ihr könntet ihm auch baumaterial zur
verfügung stellen um den schuppen auf
dem grundstück zu reparieren glaube mir
er wäre glücklich findet ohne dürfte
[Musik]
zusammen mit kati wollen sie doch einmal
mit der familie reden diesmal ist kam
lothar carlos man
architekt gesprüht schon vor ideen für
den umbau aber mike und nicole wollen
zuerst das problem mit dem ehemaligen
hausmeister lösen
die
möglichkeit
das grundstück
auf dem grundstück
[Musik]
yahoo
die bodega unten bei der großen wiese
mai kann sich kaum vorstellen dass
carmelo den alten schuppen bewohnbar
machen kann
das meinte ich es ist ein drecksloch das
geht nicht
da die wir machen es anders er kann für
uns arbeiten aber er muss ausziehen und
sich eine neue bleibe suchen
das geht wirklich nicht
hausmeister carmelo sieht das nicht so
eng er wird mike und nicole später davon
überzeugen dass er diese bodega wohnlich
umbauen kann
[Musik]
ok
marcel hat einen anstrengenden
arbeitstag in der bar hinter sich doch
zu hause ist für ihn noch nicht
feierabend
tricks hat vorhänge besorgt mit denen
sie den balkon verschönern möchte
da war hat überhaupt ist die entweder es
gebe für analytische sommers kommen oder
nicht
weiß ich nicht
marcel sehen sich nach einem moment der
ruhe in seinem neuen leben rechts
organisiert
es gibt schon noch wie
üblich auf 2 0 dass man jetzt aber
als positiv
dass ich
negativ aber damit sei es positiv dass
er diese entscheidung
zusätzlich magath
heraus wer das nicht macht und die wahl
in zwei jahren wieder eine macht aber
immer bleibt
aber dagegen stoppte xiii und auf
transit den new jersey schwarz
ich glaube drachen
der wettlauf gegen die zeit auf freie
krieg das prägende thema das ultimatum
von durchsteht nun hat die bank die das
resort hätte finanzieren sollen ihre
zusage unerwartet zurückgezogen
schön musste es einen businessplan
einmal mehr überarbeiten seine neue idee
zusätzlich zum ferien resort wurden sie
auch landwirtschaft betreiben den plan
wird er heute einer anderen bank
vorstellen
[Musik]
das heißt mit den
zusätzlichen betrag hat wirtschaft
somit mit cash crops heißt dass da wo
man zusätzlich den titel jahr plant den
goalie geplant und das ist natürlich um
wenn du einfach 20 hektar brachland hast
musst bewirtschaftet und dann kommt oder
in
einer halben stunde kommen die banker
aus coffs harbour
miriam und schuhe sind unter zugzwang
verkäufer will hat den preis zwar
gesenkt aber er will immer noch 1,9
millionen franken
sie sind einfach geschichten wir sind
letzte impuls
australische banker aber sind immer für
eine überraschung gut
[Musik]
in der nächsten folge von auf und davon
präsentieren schul und miriam den
bankern ihre neue idee
erstes kulturprogramm mit den aborigines
ehefrau miriam begrüßt dazu schweizer
gäste
auf kreta bekommt die rock und blues bar
den letzten schliff
am eröffnungstag verläuft jedoch nicht
alles nach plan
in costa rica beginnt der umbau am
hausmeisterhaus
tochter josephine aber plagt das heimweh
sie vermisst ihre freunde in der schweiz
[Musik]
die wilders neuen stoffen
si
[Musik]
huf und davos präsentiert wurde der
leyen für oliver längert oder weniger
lang weg sind